atomik circus
je retourne james dale calme est
apparent avec benoît
et mener sa part à didier notre invité
ce soir voilà sorti le 21 juillet c'est
insensé ce film quand vous avez reçu le
scénario vous avez réagi comme en ait
beaucoup ri ouais beaucoup risquent pas
essayer de remettre les palmes dans
l'ordre c'est vrai qu'ils avaient pas
mal des choses incompréhensibles et 20
des choses pas très claires mais il y
avait un le ton qu'il ya dans le film
était déjà dans ce scénario le la bande
démo des frères poro qui avait fait
beaucoup de pub et des courts métrages
et d' équipe était vraiment insensé est
très très très original et puis euh cdc
les gars sont bourrés talent est
tellement sincère et je suis très fier
d'être de faire partie de ce film qui a
été fait en france par des français avec
des acteurs presque tous français et
vash et chez fier alors les frères
poireau effectivement ce sont des
nantais 1 et ils ont fait appel pour la
musique à d'autres nantais qui s'appelle
les petits lapins des little rabbits il
ya une chanson qui est très drôle c'est
la pétroleuse
gerland d'orlando le cui parlons nous
n'y a pas d'autre marché l'année
prochaine non plus à la hollande où il
commença bien casser les couilles quand
même bon orlando et même si je veux clip
ma maîtrise
ceux ci
map être le faire m
ouais
bush en paradis avec le petit l'attend
ça s'appelle matin
nous allons récupérer
m
mais michel
beaucoup de longs mois
voir
ces trois kerry ça arrive parfois je
veux pas que les gens le public
n'accroche pas que cette chanson non
c'est pas la peine de s'acharner on aime
être à plus tard j'aime dans la chanson
c'est comme ça qu'est ce que tu veux
quoi il s'expose en droit de le faire
alors le disque sort chez barclays ce
qui veut dire que contrairement aux
rumeurs qui ont couru
vous n'êtes pas viré de chez barclays
ils ont fait d'autres chez barclay ouais
ceci étant en ce moment vous semblez
préféré vanessa paradis votre carrière
d'actrice à votre carrière de chanteuse
8e cinéma c'est les vacances de la
personnalité on devient quelqu'un
d'autre mais très entouré c'est vrai
alors que chanteuse basse et d'une
extrême solitude
on est un peu je préfère pas je préfère
passer là les projets la ville de ça ça
se présente comme ça et puis je met plus
de temps à faire les chansons maintenant
parce que je les fais un petit peu moins
avec l'aide d'autres personnes et donc
ça me prend moque t-on ce que j'essaie
les factrices et l'on vous dit je ne
suis pas gainsbourg et puis les enfants
prennent beaucoup de temps
c'est moi qui le prend beaucoup de temps
avec mes enfants parce que je n'ai rien
envie de louper c'est à vous les avez
vous-même quoi je suis allé faire élever
par d'autres préfèrent les élevez vous
même les pauvres alors question cinéma
quand même
vous venez de tourner avec le scénariste
de la fille sur le pont qui s'appelle
manqué qui a réalisé son premier film
huawei avec est un petit bijou et c'est
encore quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui
a écrit qui écrit une histoire sublimer
je viens juste de finir de le tourner
donc c'est encore assez frais avec un
jeune acteur qui s'appelle vincent
rottiers il faut retenir son nom parce
que c'est une une bombe atomique est une
perle règles à 17 ans et c est ce que tu
as son portable à vincent rottiers un
attaché de presse
on va demander qu'il appelle pour
l'inviter tout de suite leur oui alors
en tous les cas soient pas dire vanessa
c'est vous fait pas d'effort particulier
pour tournée en amérique vous dites j'ai
aucune ambition internationale vous ai
même pas d'agent hollywood
non non non pourquoi parce que enfin ils
ont déjà ils ont des gens très très bien
ils ont pas franchement besoin de nous
croient qu'ils ont besoin nous a pas
moins que ce soit un projet enfin
quelque chose de spécial mais faire la
course au projet j'ai l'impression que
tout le temps est là moi qui tourne
quand même une fois tous les 36 du mois
là bas il faudrait tourner tout l'or
tout le temps pour jamais qu on vous
oublie pied parce que je franchement
j'ai eu moi j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut
ici en france puis j'ai un peu plus
l'europe pourquoi je voyage je n'ai pas
déjà ça me prend beaucoup de temps
s'il fallait en plus que je fasse ça là
bas puis c'est bien là bas on ne montre
pas du doigt
si vous êtes sages finalement non c'est
pas vrai si voici maintenant elle élève
ses enfants elle veut pas faire la
course à hollywood
vous êtes assez sage moi je suis très
normal c'est très ennuyeux c'est bien
non pas du tout enfin je sais pas ce
qu'en pense votre johnny depp mais moi
personnellement je trouve ça bien plein
apparemment fait longtemps que cet
ensemble soit quand même temps si c'est
bien déjà et vous michel êtes quand même
temps et votre femme
trois mois alors vous avez passé le cap
des 3
ça va j'ai commencé les premiers mois
c'est les plus dures du gl nous vivons
ensemble depuis trois mois
oui sommes pas mariés encore à trois
mois c'est les noces de bistrot non
vanessa est toujours pas mariés non plus
on va mettre ça non j'ai des enfants
alors vanessa vous n'avez toujours pas
de projet avec johnny depp qui a eu
cette histoire de don quichotte pour
laquelle nous avons reçu jean rochefort
ici l'année dernière pour la sortie du
dvd bon aventure avortée terrible
histoire évidemment et c'est vrai
qu'après le succès de pirates des
caraïbes qui a fait quand même 621
millions de dollars de recettes énormes
la suite est déjà en chantier donc voilà
il est happé par sa est en fait
effectivement vous concentrer sur votre
rôle de maman surtout à los angeles où
passez votre temps entre les cours de
danse pour les enfants les ateliers
d'arts plastiques pour les enfants
le pédiatre pour les enfants et les
enfants et un poney club là bas mais
c'est bien mais j'ai comme tout le monde
ses parents proches si vous pouviez de
la coke au queen tous les soirs on vous
féliciterez pas voilà non alors entre
deux tournages vous avez votre maison
avec johnny depp dans le sud de la
france ne me reposer un petit peu voilà
l'adresse qu'il y passe
une déviation d'ax et pour 19,4
actuellement oui alors vous dites on va
au marché en cuisinant mangent ils ont
une vie terriblement simple vous vivez
une espèce de bohème très chic un petit
peu comme dans les années 70 les
rockstars d'idées comme ça quand vous
voyagez avec johnny depp j'ai quand même
30 d'alice qui vous suivent que jérôme
s'est pas de l'arrivée en voyage mais
celle aussi où il ya des freins les
meubles non par exemple j'étais d'un
exemple rend le drap qui recouvre la
table à langer les enfants soient
habitués à la couleur du drap vanessa
prend ce drap tu en voilà c'est tout ça
c'est vrai à ses veaux comme vous dites
ça mais non mais aussi parce que moi
j'en les enfants et vivent une vie de
bohème eux c'est vrai qu'on leur a pas
tellement de demander leur avis ne sont
pas l'air de s'en plaint mais il faut
quand même pas les jeux l'échangé de
maison sans arrêt sans qu'ils aient des
choses aussi qui reconnaissent qu a pour
patron
vanessa paradis et johnny depp ch et un
couple parfait c'est le bonheur absolu
donc on va faire une interview je fous
la merde